what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with donnie kate's run on the
incredible hulk and in the last video we
basically ended things seemingly with
this idea that bruce banner essentially
seemed to work for like general
thunderbolt ross or at the very least
was subservient to general thunderbolt
ross who of course had become president
of the united states now the other part
of this is this reality is given a
numerical designation which usually
happens faster than this but this is
referred to as earth 122 so maybe that's
something that will become important
later on down the line i'm not entirely
sure usually whenever marvel actually
assigns a numerical designation to an
alternate reality it usually means that
alternate reality will appear in the
future so again that's why i say you may
or may not want to keep it in the back
of your head the thing about this is
that as we know uh basically thunderbolt
ross ends up discovering or finding out
that there is a kind of enormous amount
of gamma energy that it basically spiked
from a specific mountain range and what
this does is it seems to indicate that
bruce banner is actually in hiding from
general thunderbolt ross that he's not
actually working for thunderbolt ross
per se and that what ends up happening
here is thunderbolt ross of course is
like send everything right like get all
the drop ships going and everything like
that and i want to be there when it all
happens now here's a thing to understand
this would never be allowed to happen
the president of the united states would
never be allowed to enter in active war
zone the secret service would keep that
from happening right it just like the
president's not allowed to put himself
in harm's way like that i mean he
wouldn't even be allowed to get close he
would never be allowed to enter an
active war zone
but at the end of the day as grant
morrison once said this is comics and
none of it's real so why does it matter
so here's the thing about this the big
question that we kind of had to ask here
is what's going on with the rest of the
world now we don't necessarily get this
in depth we do get a couple questions
answered but really we basically end up
finding out that it's largely tony stark
who killed the world not tony stark
directly but the technology of tony
stark that what ended up happening is
that with everything following the way
that it did right the gamma revolution
as it was called all these people with
like gamma energy basically popping up
all over the place that what it did is
it made stark technologies essentially
obsolete now this is an important thing
because before tony stark became iron
man as most of you guys know he was a
weapons manufacturer and whether it's
because you've seen the movie or you've
read the comics it was basically the art
of war right the danger that comes with
war itself and like the loss of innocent
lives and the fact that tony stark was
forced to face that fact when he was
kidnapped well really during the vietnam
war in the comics versus uh during the
afghan conflict in uh in the movies that
he ended up turning over a new leaf and
basically using his technology in order
to one make the world better as well as
turning himself into an avenger the
difference here is that because this
whole gamma revolution happened before
tony stark became iron man or at least
maybe after he became iron man this
stark industries had no real value and
so the result of this is that tony stark
filed for bankruptcy right like
literally his company's value just
plummeted because he wasn't offering
anything that was better than the whole
gamma revolution right the idea of like
gamma-powered beings and so what this
meant is that eventually his company was
absorbed now we're not really told who
it was that absorbed his company whether
it was justin hammer or anything like
that or even just the federal government
itself the important thing here is that
ultimately tony stark ended up just
dying of his alcoholism right he ended
up being found dead outside of a bar
from alcohol toxicity and basically
chronic pancreatitis following that the
technology of tony stark was basically
used presumably by the government to
kind of bridge the gap between the gamma
radiation of the incredible hulk and the
technology of stark to create these
basically gamma-powered stark uh robots
right and then in turn they started
wiping out everything right like
literally the x-men popped up shortly
after that and they were all just
annihilated by the federal government
right just totally wiped out completely
now the thing about this is that this
looks like it takes place around the
time of giant-sized x-men so not only
were the x-men eradicated by the forces
of basically the government using stark
tech but they also nuked the entirety of
the xavier's school for gifted
youngsters now we're not really given
much outside of that it's really just
kind of banner reading about all this
stuff in this alternate reality but what
we can also largely surmise here is that
when he starts asking questions like is
there nobody left right what about blade
or moon knight or like captain america
or even like spider-man that like the
response of this alternate reality
banner is like i don't okay blade or
moon like i have no idea what you're
talking about so seemingly there is no
blade there is no moon knight which is
really kind of interesting because in
the main marvel universe eric brooks
became blade pretty early on and he's
been around for quite some time so
seemingly he may still be around and
just nobody knows about him or maybe he
just never really came into existence at
all uh captain america may still very
well be frozen in ice it's just one of
those things where we're not really
given a whole lot of answers maybe we
will get them at a later point in time
but at the moment we don't really know
what's happening the crazy thing about
this though is that in the middle of all
this you basically end up having like
the forces of thunderbolt ross so
basically the u.s government that
descend on this mountain range where you
have the main marvel universe banner and
this alternate reality banner and so
what it does is it leads to like
alternate banner basically telling like
you know the the main marvel universe
panda right don't go out there right
like these this is literally an army
that's bred for the purpose of
destroying people like you right like
they they this this is not like you
running out there and dealing with like
bullets and things like that they
specialize in this it's the way what i'm
getting is that once banner shows up out
there it's just like this colossal army
with this these giant mech suits you
know what this reminds me of in a lot of
ways it reminds me of like days of
future past right it looks very very
similar today's future past this is one
of the reasons why that story was so
landmark when it came out and why it has
such a strong legacy because so often
whenever you look at alternate reality
stories where essentially the
superheroes have basically been killed
off in some form or fashion usually by
the actions of the government itself
that it is some kind of days of future
past-esque scenario right the activation
of some version of the sentinel program
sometimes the signals become self-aware
other times the sentinels never deviate
from their programming they never become
self-aware and they just operate based
on the programming given to them by the
federal government but whatever it is
the funny thing about this is banner
tells us alternate reality counterpart
no no right i'm from a whole different
playing field like i am not these gamma
mutates that you see out there right
these gamma-ray radiated beings just
watch and learn my friend i'm on a whole
different level from these guys now once
he jumps out there and and literally
ross is just like fire right fire
everything they have then it initially
takes banner by surprise right like he
didn't really believe what alternate
banner was telling him until he was
being hit with all these lasers that are
literally piercing his skin right which
is a very difficult task to achieve but
in a world full of gamma irradiated
hulks it was only a matter of time
before these before technology was
developed that could overcome those
hulks and by extension overcome this one
but as you guys know and seemingly one
of the things that makes the main marvel
universe version of the incredible hulk
so unique is that the angrier he gets
the stronger he gets and so as a result
of this literally banner just like sets
the whole the whole engine system of the
incredible hulk to stage four now
remember those of you guys who are kind
of getting caught up here that basically
it's banner controlling the mind of the
incredible hulk and by setting the
engine to stage four what he's basically
doing is forcing the incredible hulk
personality to experience like all these
different horrors in these stages of
combat which in turn makes the
incredible hulk personality angrier and
it makes the incredible hulk's body
stronger and more durable which allows
banner to continue fighting in places
that he normally wouldn't be able to
fight the thing about this is that by
going to stage four it basically
activates a kind of hallucination of the
marvel zombies so literally while like
the hulk personality is just losing its
mind attacking all these marvel zombies
it amps him up more and more his healing
factor kicks in he recovers almost
instantaneously and then like the
strength boost comes and in doing so he
starts laying waste to the forces of
thunderbolt ross right like at that
point it's really thunderbolt ross
realizing he never had a chance in the
first place right like it's just
absolute madness here and even this
alternate reality version of banner is
like my god like what the hell have i
unleashed right they have never seen
anything like this in this alternate
universe they've never seen like a tried
and true incredible hulk and that's one
of the things that donnie kate's really
seems to be hitting at is that yes you
have different iterations of the
incredible hulk from around the
multiverse but there only ever really
seems to be one version of the
incredible hulk that's as unique as this
now the reality is we know that's not
necessarily the case right i mean the
what if story based on like world war
hulk where basically hulk ends up
killing all the superheroes and becomes
a hero of galactus like that was
basically the same hulk that we were
used to who seemingly had all the same
powers right so it's not that uncommon
to see but it seems to be a fairly rare
thing and so what you end up getting is
actually general thunderbolt ross who
contacts this alternate banner and it's
just like do something right like call
this guy off if you don't call this guy
off then i'm bringing out your star
pupil right this stupid kid that you
love so much and we're gonna send them
down there and so that's the crazy thing
is because where where ross is like you
got 10 seconds right banner like
literally tries to talk him down he's
like no no like please don't do it
please don't do it he was like call your
monster off or the boy falls right the
boy gets knocked down into this whole
great big huge thing and so it's one of
those things where like this alternate
reality banner absolutely cares for this
kid right but at the end of the day he
ends up coming to thunderbolt ross and
then tells bruce spanner you have to
stop this madness right you have to stop
fighting against the forces of ross and
like the whole time bruce banner is like
what are you talking about why do i have
to stop fighting and he never really
gets an answer he doesn't shut off the
engine right he doesn't doesn't calm the
incredible hulk down that the incredible
persona keeps going crazy just like it
always did and so as a result of that
the countdown ends and ross is just like
dunzo and kicks the kid out of this
whole thing and so you have bruce banner
talking to his alternate reality banner
counterpart and it's like tell me what's
going on like what's happening here and
this alternate reality banner is like
okay so here's the thing right like this
kid was basically my star pupil right
like he was he was just he was a
research student of mine right he was
like a son to me his name was peter and
he was bitten by a spider that we had
basically irradiated now when that
happens right in that moment the forces
of general thunderbolt ross retreat they
clear the battlefield and when bruce
banner asked the question okay this is
probably stupid but this irradiated
spider that bit this kid peter what kind
of radiation are we talking about here
and what it looks like is it was a gamma
irradiated spider because what manifests
here is one of the most badass
depictions of spider-man ever right like
literally this kid lands here and he
ends up transforming into what's
basically a hulk spider-man it is
awesome oh my god you look so good this
is why i love donnie kate's man the guy
just pulls these crazy ass rabbits out
of his ass right it's just it's nuts the
kind of stuff that he does this guy's
imagination is just bonkers but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace